The numbers one, negative one, i and negative i all, when taken to the fourth
power, equal one. In case you're curious about how exactly this works, I've
written them all out for you here. I think probably taking negative i to the
fourth power is the least intuitive of these, but we know that when we multiply
two negatives together, the negative signs cancel one another our basically. So
negative i times negative i is just i squared which is negative 1. So negative i
to the fourth is really just negative 1 squared or 1. This is another way where
imaginary and real numbers interact in a super fascinating way in my opinion at
least. Who would have thought that there are all these different numbers that
are multiplied by themselves 4 times equal to 1?